bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fabi j
oggi andiamo avanti contro my thing la
serie che avevo già iniziato mi pare la
settimana scorsa
praticamente per chi ancora non l'avesse
visto consiste nel disegnare delle cose
degli oggetti che degli oggetti che
appaiono e bisogna cercare di disegnarli
per far indovinare gli altri la
particolarità di questa serie è che
praticamente l'unica che gioco con voi
ovvero i sei partecipanti di oggi sono
praticamente tra voi iscritti e per
poter partecipare basta mettere mi piace
alla pagina di facebook e ogni tanto
quando mi gira di registrare lo dico va
beh direi di partire allora andiamo con
fritz
vediamo di disegnare un frigo magari si
faccia anche la nutella
ok guardate che figo sembra sembra una
mega suppo ecco una già scritto nutella
ti stimo ma non è quello però ci sei
vicino dai dai dai che facile dai che
fatti faccio anche la nutella dentro
anche se non si tiene in frigo da bravo
bravo hai dominato quello di prima e
grana è un grande lo stimo perché questa
la nutella dentro da è fantastico è un
disegno fatto coi fiocchi
non si poteva non indovinare la cava beh
comunque o che era cambiarlo con il
prossimo mi sento carico vai lancia me
la prendo al volo
ok ragazzi amo partiti sembra uno stagno
non è uno stagno e cos'è beh fantastico
è la cosa più è una patata coi capelli
ai red pro detto lo zio sembra
l'agopuntura per una cimice non ho idea
eva porcospino porcospino porcospino e
non solo che come si scrive in inglese
porcupine sempre al nome di un pokémon
vabbè ho vinto vinto ovviamente io ho
vinto non ce ne ho tagliato un casino di
disegni in questo primo svendere 123
vuole essere tuo amico non lo accetto e
vabbè allora andiamo su wii hamsik va
bene facciamo chicken
e allora la mia abilità nel disegnare le
galline raga preparatevi
allora partiamo allora questo è guardate
che roba guardate che roba che zampe ma
chi è che ve le fa delle zampe così è
fantastico ci servono le piume ma non
importa
e vabbè allora facciamo la testa da te
cos'è cos'è sto schifo ma ce la fa c'era
se la gallina che starà dicendo
uccidetemi ok
vabbè dai non avete 61 la indovinato 1
ha indovinato mi sta bene che indovinato
nonostante io abbia fatto un obrobrio va
bene kitchen 1 ha scambiato chicken per
kitchen
io faccio schifo in inglese che la metà
basta però diciamo che ci mettete anche
nel vostro è però la cava bene
mara scrivere via fa vj fai qualcosa di
più decente minchia stima fratello ti
lovvo anch'io però non so che cos'è sta
roba
ok
bene st de rica è un cavo è un cavo
cos'è che cosa cable cable cablè cable
no c'ero quasi sono arrivato secondo
merda o tre punti sono secondo a pari
merito con un altro però non sono primo
non so il primo maledizione o ce la
cantiamo con l'ultimo sto perdendo di
prepotenza
praticamente sono quasi ultimo ma non
importa vabbè andiamo a cos'è questo
fantasma ghost ghost madonna madonna
fuori giri torna in carreggiata
peccato che è finita la partita ma non
importa secondo posto supera tutti ero
penultimo raga vabbè secondo posto mi
accontento vabbè dai come inizio non è
male una vittoria va beh la prima non
raccontiamo perché è un po un
allenamento
ok raga sono pronto questa la vinco
sicuro outlet crystal ball o dream e
crystal boll andiamo con crystal ball è
ok proviamo a fare una roba ci ho che ci
provo ma non so quanto cos'è sta roba
cos'è megan fox ci hai preso in pieno
va beh direi di fare una roba un po più
no che schifo raga come faccio a fare
una crystal boll è impossibile
ma facciamo una strega a sto punto che
guarda è però mi sembra cos'è cos'è è
pinocchio e pinocchio è la cosa più
stupida di sempre ma meglio di così non
posso farlo abbiate pietà
e vabbè se va bene avete indovinato
tutti sono veramente fantastici vostri
disegni ragazzi credetemi viviamo però
non ho ben capito cos'è sta roba è un
emo cos'è una mummia mummia come si
diceva mia non mi ricordo non mia ma
edizione come [ __ ] ma ma a me ho
indovinato
vabbè questa in effetti era uscita
abbastanza bene soltanto dai raga non
indovina nessuno state messi peggio di
merd inglese va beh non importa sono a
pari merito con la persona che appena
disegnato la mummia devo arrivare
assolutamente primo cos'è questo libro
bookbook boc non ha fine window windows
windows e fa vj no non è fa vj secondo
me cos'è attacco figurina card card se
c'è non si posso credere
a furia di aver passato l'infanzia
giocare con sta merda
sono riuscito a indovinarla va beh
grazie kamen dominato tutti ho vinto ho
vinto ok andiamo con un altro la
fireflies mangiamo con fuochi
d'artificio vediamo se riesco mi sembra
no cos'è sta merda
devo riuscire a fare una roba abbastanza
semplice anche se penso che uscirà una
cagata assurda come al solito però che
si capisca più o meno allora questi sono
i miei fuochi d'artificio mi sembrano le
bacchette magiche la fantagenitori però
altro non mi vieni raga non so come
disegnarli altrimenti ma fai flai vuol
dire fuochi d'artificio no lucciole che
cazzo disegnato ok ho sbagliato radio ha
fatto una stronzata
erano lucciole volevo fare pensavo era
fireworks fuochi d'artificio non
fireflies [ __ ] ma che ne so io
addio se sbaglio cos'è questo cos'è sta
roba è una lucciola sono un artista
mancato ok ragastas cos'è sta roba
water water mare come si dice mai 8
cos'è è semplicemente la parola blu
forse bruno loro infatti in tempo la fa
ancora perché perché non ho fatto in
tempo porca [ __ ] sono l'unico
deficiente che non l'ha indovinata c'è
sono a zero
dai che posso mai essere a zero punti
c'è questo laga la dice lunga su quanto
io abbia avuto un culo assurdo nel primo
episodio perché veramente essere a zero
e deprimente ma non importa
andiamo avanti prova una parola a caso
scrapbook se la indovinare raga andavo
in giro nudo per tutta italia sono a 0
punti ragazzi sto per battere un record
mondiale non ne faccio neanche uno
queste street stritt no non è street
[ __ ] devo indovinarne almeno ma
non posso rimanere a 0
vabbè cos'è kacar carcar autobus raga
non possono indovinare neanche una
che ne so io scusa scusa school bus
scomposta
no non ci posso credere no neanche
ancora zero no c'è ma avevo anche
indovinata non ci posso credere a zero e
avevo anche indovinata non è possibile
né marc houle se non indovino questa mi
faccio prete perché veramente non possa
fa un po stonato e carne neanche una
cos'è
ma cos'è skate skate board ma [ __ ]
non è possibile ma non è possibile non
faccio mai in tempo a scrivere niente
sono a 0ra gao chiuso a zero o mio dio
fabio ultimo essi bravi bravi bravi
denis dette quelli che non fanno neanche
un punto e adesso che ci penso se io
mettevo un mio cugino di tre anni al
posto mio
faceva il mio stesso punteggio perché
lui non sa scrivere sulla tastiera però
è non sarebbe cambiato molto il
punteggio in generale quindi io ho fatto
come un bambino di tre anni
ok andiamo su compasso proviamo a fare
un compasso che non è comparso ma e
bussola ovviamente il mio inglese
italianizzato non poteva mancare andiamo
sulla bussola
questa è la n questa è cosa c'è giu sud
ok facciamo in inglese sì andiamo con la
w è est ok questo è facile non mi
criticate per come disegno perché è
facile un'ala indovinato 2 se mi sento
un pro
se avete indovinato questa è
e se ce l'ho fatta l'avete dominata in
quattro un gran traguardo va bene dai
sono soddisfatto di me stesso fa
abbastanza schifo ma non importa
sì grazie fatto bene lo so so che sono
avanti non utile che me lo dite
vabbè ok laga cos'è sta roba è un cd è
una patata è una faccia è l'ultimo album
di madonna
come avete fatto a indovinarlo non è
possibile c'è ma ma come cazzo fate
indovinarle subito ceva smile che cazzo
ne non è mai perché ci ha quattro
lettere cos'è la face
porca [ __ ] che schifo faccia sto gioco
che sono anche prima adesso che guardo
però 5 punti parigi in testa e vabbè
allora deve indovinare flag flag flag
flag no
cos'è e cosa mia cartellone cartellone è
una ics cos'è dove indovinarlo
assolutamente start start non è start
start no
cosa mi rappresenta cos'è questo ragazzo
ma fatelo de cento almeno l'ultimo cos'è
la maledizione l'anno indovinato ma
posso ancora farcela possa ancora
farcela
non lo so cos'è non ho idea maledice
peas e la bandiera della pace
hai disegnato la croce sull'arma ma mio
dio sono arrivato terno non sono
arrivato terzo sono arrivato 12 34 c
quinto quinto quinto su 7 non so chi è
questo raga non ne ho idea ma tanta
stima per la foto
no perché ho fatto ignare va beh non
importa vabbè raga direi di concludere
qui se volete partecipare anche voi
ricordo di mettere mi piace la pagina di
facebook che trovate nella descrizione è
praticamente quando mi gira di
registrare draw my thing lo scrivo nella
pagina di facebook ai primi che
partecipano saranno appunto nel prossimo
episodio
preparatevi per domani che se tutto va
bene dovrebbe uscire il viso speciale
per i 15.000 iscritti è come al solito
se il video vi è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come non i video trovate nella
descrizione se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
mito bella ragazzi